[Musique]
c'est un grand mélange d'émotions une
anticipation et une tristesse
le mélange d'émotions fortes mais on est
très forte c'est un jour historique pour
rabais raquette aujourd'hui âgé de 75
ans cet avocat de montréal a cherché
toute sa vie a retrouvé des traces de
son père
ça dépasse tout ce que j'ai pu imaginer
espérer aujourd'hui pour la première
fois il va naviguer tout près du site
fluviale ou l'avion de chasse de son
père s'est abîmé le 31 mars 1951 et ce
serait comme à quasiment un miracle de
trouver ça couve comme ça d'un seul coup
je pense que c'est le début d'un
processus on a deux facteurs à respecter
des distances de profondeur le capitaine
du bateau et jean marc perrault
passionnés d'histoire qui enseigne les
sciences au secondaire
c'est lui le grand responsable de cette
aventure qui vise à retrouver la
carlingue d'un avion de l'armée
canadienne
lagardère
de 9 heures et peut-être les restes de
son pilote guy harding hackett
guy hackett avait participé à la
deuxième grande guerre comme pilote de
mosquito l'avion de chasse célèbre et
puissant ses missions au dessus du
territoire allemand était extrêmement
audacieuse
comme l'a découvert son fils robert des
décennies plus tard l'idée c'était
d'intercepter les avions allemands qui
rentrait
atterrir chez eux tout était en noirceur
mais pour recevoir les avions vous
allumez c'est à ce moment là les gars
uzi aller et vous et vous essayez de
fusiller
ça prenait des nerfs de faire ça prenait
de l'audace ceux-ci l'origine un qui m'a
envoyé mon père lors de sa dernière
mission en février 1945 l'avion de guy
raquette est touché par des tirs de la
défense allemande ça c'est le plan des
territoires où ils avaient été capturés
en langue est fait prisonnier par les
nazis il sera libéré cinq mois plus tard
à la fin de la guerre à l'âge de 26 ans
id est revenu un homme fait complètement
transformé qui buvaient beaucoup qui
était violent c'était ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui post traumatique un syndrome
post traumatique rbds et moi faire
[Musique]
dans les années qui suivent guy à kate
se marie devient père est avocat ils
recommencent à voler dans l'armée de
réserve il prend les commandes d'un des
premiers avions à réaction le vampire
c'est à bord de cet aéronef qu'il
effectue un vol d'entraînement au dessus
du sel euros le jour fatidique ce
matin-là y avait un grand brouillard et
ta réaction d'un gars qui a l'habitude
de voler à 25 pieds de la terre c'était
on va passer par en dessous on va l'en
son aile gauche a touché l'eau est
évident qu'en un bout des ailes d'un
avion tu touches à 309 alors ces
désastres les avions légers vu poser
absolue et parler aux gens
de guise avait 13 ans à cette époque il
est probablement le dernier témoin
oculaire de l'accident sans poigne au
chaos
70 ans plus tard il se rappelle bien de
la scène des bancs de brouillard qui
obstruait la vue cet après midi là je
vis deviens pour seuls outils de l'eau
du charest voudrait tant à bord et est
déjà élevé il avions ramené 4 attendu
bonbons mous et
le résident de sereine se souvient
d'avoir récupéré réservoir à essence
provenant d'un des deux avions que le
courant avait transporté devant chez lui
lorsqu'en fait leur recherche l'eau
était très haute avec d'après moi l'eau
est à la limite violent
les recherches menées par les forces
canadiennes ont duré d'une dizaine de
jours le mauvais temps la présence de
glace et la mauvaise visibilité
les ont forcés à les interrompre mais
c'est finalement la femme du pilote qui
a demandé de tout arrêter de peur que
d'autres personnes perdent la vie
[Musique]
ils ont remonté plus beaucoup plus de
pièces de des delles deux parties de
fuselage de moteurs etc de l'avion de
mip est moins de pièces de l'avion de
mon père
robert à qui tu avais presque cinq ans
au printemps 1951 quand le drame est
survenu 70 ans plus tard cette histoire
l'habite toujours
c'est comme fondamental à mon petit chez
tout ça oui alors l'idée que le
fait se cherche son père c'est ses
profonds
[Musique]
la viande mon père serait celui qui est
plus au nord nord est selon elle on l'a
le capitaine perreault a identifié des
cibles d'intérêt de quoi encourager sa
petite équipe composée de ses meilleurs
élèves à poursuivre les recherches
on trouve quelque chose on ne touche à
rien on n'a pas le droit de toucher ni
remontée quoi que ce soit et l'armée une
équipe spéciale pour l'identification
des dépouilles de guerre parmi les
épaves donc on va penser le relais
[Musique]
il soit comme ça faut pas que ça ça
tombe dans l'oubli
j'essaie de réunir un fils et son père
c'est vraiment ce que cherche à faire
le capitaine n'a pas eu de succès ce
jour là il espère reprendre les
recherches avec des équipements plus
sophistiqués au printemps
quant à nous raconter ah oui ben moi
aussi
grâce aux recherches entreprises par
jean marc perrault les forces armées
canadiennes ont décidé d'honorer cette
année la mémoire des pilotes disparus
j'inviterais maintenant monsieur
moubarak
en fait du chef d'escadrille est à vous
offrir
les restes sont là depuis le 31 mars 51
quand son avion de chasse et celui de
son collègue rob lit peu of hurter le
fleuve de plein fouet
[Musique]
c'est une étape majeure majeur est tout
à fait inattendu
robert à kate réfléchit à ce qu'il fera
si on retrouve un jour les restes de son
père les retirer pour les inhumer
[Musique]
les laisser sur place au fond de l'eau
en tout respect pour la mémoire de son
cher père pilotes téméraires
c'est important de dire face à ta tombe
je te salue mon père
[Musique]